se determinó la secuencia de aminoácidos
del citocromo se para cinco especies
diferentes de vertebrados la siguiente
tabla muestra el número de diferencias
en las secuencias entre cada par de
especies sólo para tener el contexto de
lo que estamos hablando estamos hablando
del citocromo sé que es una proteína
probablemente la recuerdas de cuando
estudiamos la cadena de transporte de
electrones no es necesario que se pase
eso para responder a esta pregunta pero
es una proteína que se encuentra en un
montón de especies diferentes y vamos a
comparar las diferencias en la secuencia
de aminoácidos de esa proteína en
diferentes especies así que aun cuando
tenemos la misma proteína o una proteína
similar a todas las llamamos citocromo c
la secuencia puede ser ligeramente
diferente cuando se pasa de una especie
de vertebrado a otra y la manera de leer
esta tabla es la siguiente para cada una
de estas filas por ejemplo esta fila
describe a
y polylepis y podemos ver el número de
diferencias entre la secuencia de
polylepis y los 18 diferencias por
supuesto va a haber 0 diferencias cuando
se compara una especie consigo misma muy
bien ahora vamos a responder a la
pregunta utilizando los datos en la
tabla crea un árbol filogenético en la
plantilla proporcionada que refleja las
relaciones evolutivas de los organismos
proporciona argumentos para la
colocación en el árbol de la especie que
tiene menor relación con las otras
especies mirando estas diferencias es
razonable decir que las especies que
tienen la menor cantidad de diferencias
en la secuencia del citocromo se
probablemente son las que están más
estrechamente relacionadas por acá nos
dieron un árbol
así que las especies que vayan a estar
aquí y aquí probablemente están
relacionadas muy estrechamente no
deberían tener demasiadas diferencias en
sus secuencias del citocromo se y estos
dos deben ser bastante similares no
deberían tener muchas diferencias entre
sí mientras que esta debe de tener un
buen número de diferencias cuando se
compara con cualquiera de las otras
cuatro especies así que primero vamos a
ver cuáles tienen muy pocas diferencias
y solo estoy analizando esta tabla en
busca de los números más pequeños
podemos ver aquí que sólo hay un
aminoácido diferente entre el citocromo
se de
fergus y africanos así que yo diría que
estos están estrechamente relacionados
probablemente tienen un antepasado común
que no está demasiado lejos en el pasado
así que voy a escribir por acá
feroz y de africanos muy bien ahora
donde más vemos algunos números pequeños
veo este 3 por aquí que es el número de
aminoácidos diferentes entre galos y a
forster y así que esas especies
probablemente están muy estrechamente
relacionadas así que voy a escribir por
acá que galos y a forster y muy bien
ahora qué especie nos falta bueno nos
falta de polylepis ya notamos a las
otras cuatro especies por lo que voy a
ponerlo por aquí d
polylepis y se puede ver que cuando
comparamos a de polylepis con cualquiera
de las otras especies
hay una diferencia bastante grande de
polylepis y fergus tienen 21 aminoácidos
diferentes 18 aminoácidos diferentes en
comparación con juega los 17 con forster
y y hay 20 aminoácidos diferentes entre
la secuencia del citocromo sede de
polylepis y africanos por lo que esta
especie tiene el mayor número de
diferencias y nos piden que
proporcionamos argumentos para la
colocación en el árbol de la especie que
tiene menor relación con las otras
especies así que vamos a proporcionar
nuestro argumento de polylepis
la especie
- relacionada debido a que tiene el
mayor número
de diferencias
en su secuencia
de aminoácidos
comparada
con las otras
cuatro especies porque incluso si
comparamos feroz con galos el número no
se acerca a 20 mientras que de polylepis
tiene una diferencia cercana a 20 con
todas las demás especies por lo que
tiene lógica que incluso estos cuatro
compartan un ancestro común y no se
tiene que ir tan lejos en el tiempo para
llegar al antepasado común de estas
cuatro como con el antepasado común con
de polylepis muy bien ahora vamos a
hacer el inciso b así que este es el
inciso a y ahora vamos con el inciso b
identifica si los datos morfológicos o
los datos de la secuencia de aminoácidos
tienen más probabilidades de representar
con precisión las verdaderas relaciones
evolutivas entre las especies y
proporciona argumentos para tu respuesta
por datos morfológicos se refiere a
observar la morfología de las diferentes
especies es decir cuál es la forma de su
espina dorsal o sus diferentes huesos
de diferentes partes de su cuerpo
mientras que con la secuencia de
aminoácidos vemos cómo están compuestas
sus proteínas personalmente escogería
los datos de la secuencia de aminoácidos
así que yo creo
que los datos
de la secuencia
de aminoácidos
tienen más probabilidades
de representar
la verdadera
relación
evolutiva
y ahora voy a dar mi argumento
dos especies
podrían tener
morfologías
convergentes es decir por ejemplo
podríamos mirar las alas de un
murciélago y las alas de un pájaro y
decir mira tienen morfología similares
pero eso no significa que estén
relacionados solo porque ambos tienen
alas o podríamos mirar a un delfín y un
pez y decir como ambos tienen aletas
probablemente están estrechamente
relacionados tienen tipos de cuerpos
similares pero sólo son morfologías
convergentes ambos proceden de ancestros
diferentes y sus antepasados debido a
que se encontraban en ambientes
similares tienen morfologías
convergentes dos especies podrían tener
morfologías convergentes
y
encontrarse
lejos
una de la otra
en el árbol
filogenético
ahora también hay argumentos a favor de
la morfología porque por ejemplo aquí
sólo estamos viendo el citocromo sé que
podría estar presentando algún tipo de
anomalía o tal vez hay algo de
convergencia o divergencia para una
proteína en particular que no está
relacionada con lo que realmente ocurrió
en la historia evolutiva pero en general
prefiero mirar las secuencias
moleculares mirar las secuencias de
proteínas y ver lo que está pasando con
el adn
yo prefiero hacer eso porque te permite
no ser engañado por la morfología
convergente de especies instantes como
los murciélagos y las aves o los
delfines y los peces